just to be clear physics is doing what
it does right it's not trying to screw
you over
[Music]
this is Star Talk a cosmic queries
edition of a special kind I'm Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and we're going to title
this one the physics of being Steve-O
Stevo this is this is the man of Jackass
what one of many players in that
franchise so Stevo welcome to StarTalk
well thank you for having me it's
exciting oh yeah thank you thank you and
your comedian a professional stuntsman
um and best known for participating in
the franchise jackass which not only on
TV but multiple movies uh you've got a
new book out let me get the title of
this book because it was like here it is
a hard kick in the nuts what I've
learned from a lifetime of terrible
decisions uh people like this is like a
sounds like a self-help topic and people
get totally get into that topic so I
wish you well on that we'll talk more
about it and you've got a bucket list
tour
so this is your on stage you're doing
crazier more extreme stunts than ever
made it to the screen or to television
is this on in a theater State what is
this context for this
and tour theaters
um you know from like one thousand to
two thousand seats and it's a multimedia
show so the crazier stuff than ever
before happened as I put the show
together and
um after each bit in the show I pay it
off by playing video of the story that I
just wow okay okay and so you were a
household name in an entire demographic
uh of this country and in fact when we
put out our request for questions
um it was like flooded with people who
are your fans and who want to see
whatever might be the mix of the stunts
that you do with whatever physics might
be behind it either physics you've
thought of or haven't and I'm here to
fill in some of those blanks uh if
necessary and plus in this particular
episode you are serving as my co-host
all right I love it so you'll be reading
the questions that people have sent to
you so
um but before we start that
uh what have have psychologists looked
closer at you to see what's going on
inside your head
um I don't think so and I think it's
pretty uh straightforward I'm an
attention [ __ ] oh that's okay that that
book there it is you got the whole
explanation yeah it's really that simple
and speaking of physics quite literally
one hour ago I was jumping a skateboard
onto a moving car
this was uh my plan I just bought a new
Tesla Model Y and uh and and I had a
vision of of the car coming towards me
and jumping up onto the hood and
skateboarding over and dropping off the
back of course because it has that very
curved Dew Drop shape to it why yep I
was looking at it I thought that I
thought that that
um was very skatable okay you didn't
actually do this you just thought of
doing it I know I I was just jumping
onto it but but I didn't complete the
whole thing I got um a friend of mine to
build uh build the hood a little further
down so that it does so that I could
it's kind of a wedge ramp which the
Tesla was pushing and
um so that I could get on to the hood
more more easily okay so you might have
died before this podcast yeah it was
only going five miles an hour
okay you might have been injured before
this podcast okay I might have yeah I've
still got to work to do though uh we
need to build something onto the back
all right so he's still still dreaming
that one up okay well I'm glad you you
survived for this podcast because I I'd
feel bad if if that if that never did
that one didn't work out uh so you say a
bucket list tour normally a bucket just
things you want to do before you die
correct and these are things that you
might die doing so you're doing them
before you die or is it just things
you've dreamed up your whole life and
thought you put them all in one show
correct that that's their ideas that
I've had for for in in some cases
decades and
um it's not like a morbid like I'm gonna
die so I've gotta hurry up and do these
things it's more a case of
uh
me recognizing that there's a finite
amount of time left for me to be able to
do these type of crazy stunts as when
you're an old man on the porch it's not
happening right right I mean like that's
the first thing I say in the show notice
that I find myself in a terrible
situation I'm Steve-O in my 40s and uh I
think that it gets a good little laugh
and the idea that wow you know Stevo in
my 40s
it's like if you were Stevo in your 20s
when all this began right correct so uh
you got questions there do you want to
start reading to him again the first
question comes from Chris knopp
uh for Stevo long time fan ever since
your earliest days of filmmaking always
able to produce some good laughs and
frankly ballsy stunts that no one else
would be willing to do has there ever
been anything intriguing about science
and physics for you and if so what
sparked it yeah because what I would say
there is you you know you can't go at
your stunts
just as a you got to understand some
laws of motion gravity there's got to be
some Physics Foundation within you right
for sure you attempt much of this so how
does that all settle out within you yeah
um the the question continues has your
career changed this for you such as
injuries forcing you to learn more about
these things
um okay so
um I think that has there ever been
anything intriguing about science and
physics for you again I'm an attention
[ __ ] I've always sought to
um you know make an impact on people to
to be notable to be uh shocking and
entertaining and um my way of going
about that was to do stunts and the
stunts that I've done
um
the stunts that I do are designed to
make me appear really crazy like before
this guy he could die he's out of his
mind like this is so this is so wild and
unhinged when in reality
for the most part everything that you
see me do is something that's I started
doing on a very low level and just
gradually worked my way up in the
beginning it was it was it was it was a
lot of jumping off of uh like buildings
into swimming pools like across gaps and
um you know I would be doing a flip off
of a three-story roof into four feet of
water
and uh there's some Physics in that you
know
I just start off uh you know on the just
the the second floor balcony and then go
to the third floor you know and learn
how to hit the water and curve in so
that's one example of uh of things where
um I I that's a very important
Revelation what you're saying what
you're telling us and thank you for even
admitting this is that you have made
your stunts safer than they look
um by Design 100 but and that's the
whole Foundation of it so so it really
has to say do not try this at home
because if you just try it at home you
would not have put in the homework
necessary to end up Surviving and even
thriving in the face of those stunts
correct and we always did have that
warning uh the these stunts are
performed by professionals do not
attempt anything you're about to see and
um I think that there's a contingent of
the audience that sees that warning and
maybe they're dyslexic to some extent
because it says dare
oh
I dare you
and YouTube is full of such dares yes
right so did you take much uh did you
take physics in high school
um I dad
I I suppose I did
I just remember like I did quite well in
in school I mean I don't know quite well
I was uh like a solid B student and and
you know a good kid
um through uh the first couple years of
high school and then in um my my junior
year of high school that was when I I
sampled a marijuana cigarette and then
oh uh oh Reefer Madness here it comes
yeah and it uh it kind of had me um you
know stop doing quite so well in school
and and um I remember trigonometry did
not go very well
yeah 11th grade yeah that's trigonometry
right there
trigonometry and weed do not mix
the title of your book
that's your next book okay
I love that
by that measure I think physics and weed
don't mix either so uh-huh there was a
there were a number of classes I really
underperformed in and physics may have
been one of them so what what I would
say is there's a lot of physics you can
glean by trial and error and as you said
you did it smartly by incrementing your
steps but I can say that if you if you
take some Physics even this late in your
life you might see other stunts you
could perform
once you realize what the physics is
doing Beyond whatever you were sort of
inventing in your your crazy sleepless
nights right
right that's just thought I don't know
if I'm gonna end up taking a physics
class but uh but
okay I mean put it on my radar on your
radar physics to know some Physics is to
be good at matter motion and energy
right think about those three things and
all three of those are completely balled
up in what it is you do because your
body is in motion you land from Gravity
you and in physics you get to calculate
all of that right and you get to see
well how fast can I go before that
happens or what is the friction between
me and that surface can I reduce the
friction or increase the friction
depending on what you need these are
entire chapters in an introductory
physics book so so there's one I've got
on my to-do list
um which will happen uh in the beginning
of next year
it's it's rather simple I bought a car a
Smart car
I bought a smart car for the
for the purpose of crashing it into a
brick wall to make sure the airbags work
okay but there's more cards that little
car that you can park almost anywhere
between two other cars right right and
um and I just love the irony of doing
that in a smart car you know
um
but the thing is this is where I'm gonna
need the physics because
um it's not something that I can start
small and work my way up if I'm crashing
this car into the water there's only one
shot at doing this yeah yeah yeah and
don't want it to be
underwhelming and I don't want it to be
too much where where I really get hurt
so I need you're in the car when it
happens oh yeah yeah that's the whole
point oh you said I'm going to crash
this car into a wall I'm gonna drive the
car into the wall so and this is the
smallest car in the marketplace
okay okay so that could be your tomb at
the end I've got it I've got to figure
out the science of that one to get The
Sweet Spot about what's going to be the
most impressive uh rate of speed into
the wall okay here's what you do
here's what you do you go knock on the
door of the ntsa national Transportation
safety Association and say lend me one
of your Crasher test dummies yeah
to dress up as a crash test dummy okay
you got that thought out already no so
what you need is look at their data and
they will show you at what speed above
which because they test all these cars
right because they have to report their
safety records before they're even
marketed so you find out at what speed
before the chest or the crash test dummy
collapsed or before their kneecaps broke
by you know by the by the front of the
car moving into their legs so you should
be able to get some prior data on this
right it's gonna be great you know
there's another one I was on tour in uh
Niagara Falls and and I I got just
interested and looked up a video of
people who went over Niagara Falls
deliberately and it was a fascinating
video I watched about it I think there
had been like 12 people or so who who
did it deliberately and it became
evident by the end of this video that
the people who put like real effort into
planning it out fared pretty well you
know
and so I got kind of obsessed with the
idea and I reached out to this uh this
company that um that works for NASA but
it's not called NASA but they work in
Pasadena
that they did these all the the
scientists in Pasadena maybe it's Jeff
propulsion Labs could it be them that's
a branch of NASA and they're in Pasadena
what's it called
um and uh I didn't hear back from them
there I was guys asked and I wanted to
help building a crash capsule to go over
Niagara Falls and yeah I probably would
not have returned those emails either
in all fairness to right the rational
Universe out there but go on and my
buddy my buddies from Jackass Chris
Pontius
um masterfully got me to stop pursuing
that idea by telling me dude it's been
done
you know I'm like we're Pioneers man you
know we do things that have never been
done don't go uh don't go you know doing
other people's stuff yeah actually well
we're gonna take a quick break when we
come back we'll get to the next question
with Steve-O all right one of the great
jackasses of Our Generation when
StarTalk returns
we're back Star Talk Cosmic queries
Edition I've got Steve-O right here with
us who is a beloved participant in the
jackass franchise from the beginning and
he's got a new book with got the best
title ever a hard kick in the nuts what
I've learned from a lifetime of terrible
decisions
and Granny's on a bucket list tour uh
visiting a theater near you to
demonstrate some of the craziest stuff
he's ever dreamed up so uh Steve oh
thanks for being on Star Talk and you've
been not only my guest but my co-host uh
reading the questions that have come to
us from our patreon fan base so why
don't you read the next question now
okay here we go this comes from uh Dade
Bloomfield
hey hello Dad from Milwaukee here Stevo
have you ever done the math to see how
fast your porta potty slingshot was
going oh yeah
for me that was the most famous one I'm
sorry that was that one nothing else
compared to that for me but yeah I I
don't disagree I think that that was uh
that was my most iconic jackass moment
and uh I I was never too concerned with
how fast it was going but I think how
high it was going or you know how high
it went is is probably the most notable
perhaps because I think it was a good
hundred feet in the air 100 feet in the
air so as you know in modern uh baseball
they calculate all manner of Statistics
from a hit ball with the exit angle is
what the exit velocity is how fast the
bat was moving and so you could just
invite some of those folks anytime you
do a projectile stunt uh they could have
it totally analyzed for you
um the the other side so just remind me
inside that porta potty it was it clean
or it was it was not it was not cringing
um the uh the idea was for it to be
filled with poo however as
um
uh you know
a part of the the Motion Picture film
Association
um you know that we have to abide by
um what's called Osha Osha occupational
safety safety hazards yeah
Administration yeah yeah
so according to OSHA
um it was against the rules to fill the
porta potty with human poo
however it was not against the rules of
Osha to fill the porta potty with dog
poop
and if you can believe it
they found a company which sold poop
like you could buy as much dog poop as
you wanted and the name of the company
believe it or not I swear I'm not making
this up it was that this company was
called we do do do
and uh they buy they bought lots and
lots of dog poop and filled up the porta
potty with that so this is for all needs
that people have for dog food
right and and uh hey I'll tell you I I I
had uh just gotten two dogs around the
time of that movie and um after I filmed
that bit when I would walk my dogs and
and pick up their poo I would bend over
pick up the poo and I'd look at it and
think man I am gnarly
I'm a gnarly guy
well yeah what's the subtitle of your
book uh what I've learned from a
lifetime of terrible decisions yeah so
are there are there moments from that
book that you can share that are sort of
other sort of crazy moments that maybe
oh yeah sort of thought twice about it
yeah
um there was uh
for for my second comedy special
I I
um
because there's a multimedia thing all
of my my comedy is is multimedia and so
I wanted to have a really big fantastic
ending and the idea I came up with for
that was to
bring in
um like a pyrotechnics guy and uh get
real like impressive explosions going on
to like blow up my living room of my
house with me in it and and I had all
these silly little things blowing up and
each thing was a little bit more
um sort of uh
ambitious than the last and it got kept
getting away with all these these uh
explosion stunts and you know nothing
was happening to me and so ultimately I
decided Well I've got to get like kind
of hurt you know like I can't just walk
away with this nothing happened
by the end of this shoot uh I actually
my buddies and I were like we were uh
hollowing out model rocket engines and
uh so this this rocket engine fuel from
the model rocket engines we have
sprinkled into Estes makes these rockets
and I remember the D engine was the
largest engine and you put several of
those you build the Saturn V rocket they
had one of those wow so yeah so you knew
where to get your explosives is what
you're saying yeah we we we got a lot of
model rocket engines we had a whole team
hollowing them out in the garage and we
um
sprinkled uh sprinkled the the rocket
engine fuel all over my living room
floor
and um
I laid down in it and did snow angels
and my buddies lit it with me laying in
it and uh
I wonder uh for the people watching I've
got the the
t-shirt that I was wearing when I laid
in the the rocket engine fuel framed on
this wall oh my gosh
okay so for those who are watching he's
walking up to his wall
and oh it's in a picture frame
okay
yeah I think they could see that pretty
good yeah yeah no it's in a picture
frame yeah it was that's true I ended up
uh I I ended up five days later in a
burn unit uh having skin graft surgery
on 15 of my body
so this sounds like one day
you're not going to get through it if it
keeps accelerating in this way that's
what it feels like to me or or
um it sounds like uh I've closed the
book on the fire stunts okay okay
you know there's certain things there's
certain times when when you gotta
recognize you've you've reached the end
of a trail yeah I'd say 15 skin graft
yes the end of the trail there comes
back totally yeah but you got another
question
uh that I think we actually just
answered it
um Connor home asks hey Stevo when has
physics screwed you over the most
and are you physics just to be clear
physics is doing what it does okay it's
not it's not trying to screw you over it
has no it has no agency oh you know
there's there's so much I'd love to talk
to you about in this regard like the the
concept of good and bad is uh it's such
a a mental construct that we've come up
with there is no such thing as good or
bad there's simply that which is
yeah well okay no there's that which is
and then you Nuance it with a good or
bad right the is is more foundational
clearly than whether or not that is is
good or bad and you can say is it good
for my health or longevity or is it bad
for you so you can ask those those
questions okay I like that I like to
save some of those for the end we can go
get all philosophical if you want yeah
for sure there's um
there's no such thing as punishment
there's just the the law of cause and
effect okay
exactly okay and uh Connor's question
continues uh he says and are you still
able to contribute to the process of
producing children
um
[Music]
how politely asked that was I I've been
this is actually part of my bucket list
show
um there was there was an idea the
oldest idea of the law on The Bucket
List
um
it was called the vasectomy Olympics
and I was inspired by a joke I heard
when I was 12 years old which was what
is the definition of Macho it's a man
who jogs home from his own vasectomy and
uh you know being the attention [ __ ]
that I am I've never wanted anything
more than to be to be macho and I grew
up with the idea that I would get a
vasectomy and then then really go really
go nuts
well we we need evidence of your
vasectomy I think oh I I I got that
covered it's a multimedia show oh okay
yeah of course duh of course I've got uh
I've gotten the most hilarious
mastectomy video ever produced
but before I got the mastectomy I could
not
uh
I just couldn't do it without first
going to get a sperm count at the
fertility clinic because people have
been asking me the same question like
after all the terrible things that have
happened to your nuts can you still
could you have kids even if you wanted
and um
and uh that what I learned when I went
to the the fertility clinic
um the the average man has Believe It or
Not 20 to 30 million sperm per
millimeter or per milliliter of semen
yeah yeah
and your boy clocked in at 51 million
so what you're saying is over all these
years your nuts have actually been
stimulated right if it doesn't kill you
it actually makes you stronger
except despite the fact that I've got uh
and a remarkably High sperm count like
they're they're all swimming sideways
they're all in wheelchairs
yeah that's worth noting uh oh so just
to finish out on the laws of physics so
I I'm just defending the laws of physics
that they have no agency here that
they'll do whatever the laws of physics
allow them to and so it's a matter of
you navigating that that's really all
that's going on is it safe to describe
the laws in physics as the natural law
of cause and effect is there any
difference
um there are some things that have no
obvious cause like radioactivity uh when
uh when an element decays from a higher
element for a heavier element to a
lighter element
it does it on its own time we cannot
predict when it will happen it's sitting
there minding its own business and then
bada bing it changes and without any
obvious cause so we're forced to say it
just is right now what is true is that
all the atoms of a particular kind
have a very repeatable half-life okay so
the half-life is over this amount of
time half of them remain yet to convert
to another element and then that you
wait the same amount of time in half
again and so it keeps having all the way
down and so some live a longer time some
don't
and it's a mystery per atom what each
atom is going to do next so I can't call
that a cause and effect
okay I love that and uh
yeah it makes perfect sense all right we
can time for just one more before this
break okay let's do it from Aaron hey
Stevo and Neil this is Aaron writing in
from Richmond Richmond Virginia here's a
question you can both weigh in on in the
fart mask stunt from Jackass 2 do you
think there was a real possibility The
Mask could explode from the amount of
methane being produced by Preston Lacy
thanks for doing this episode yeah dude
yeah I didn't answer this I love that I
love that uh what I'll lead off and then
when we come back from the break you
pick it up okay so just lay down some
Physics here in some chemistry so
methane is chemically the the element
carbon attached to say it's four four
hydrogen atoms so it's CH4 and it is the
byproduct
of
of microbes
basically digesting the eating I would
call it digesting eating their food in
an environment that has no oxygen
so deep in your gut there's no Oxygen so
it's where we say anaerobic so that's
deep in your gut and so there are
microbes that just love it there and one
of their byproducts is methane which
happens to be highly flammable
it is highly flammable and so that old
trick you might have heard in in Camp
okay let's try to light their farts you
know that actually comes from
foundations in chemistry and physics
there's energy stored in that molecule
and so that if you bring a flame to it
you break apart that molecule and energy
gets released and depending on how much
of it's there it'll just be a so a flash
of a flame or it could be an actual
explosion
so that's just to get the physics laid
down and so now when we come back we're
going to find out what the hell were you
thinking and and we'll look at the risk
factors of your face blowing up when
start talk continues uh Cosmic queries
with Stevo of Jackass infamy and
so we're back StarTalk Cosmic queries
with Steve O who's got who's entering
His Bucket List tour at a theater near
you is it just called The Bucket List
tour or there's another name on The
Bucket List tour Stevo and the bucket
list tour that's all the information you
need it's actually uh somewhat winding
down now okay I'm about to go on a run
through Canada and then I've got uh some
U.S dates after that
um and and that that's what the book
lives on
and remind me the title of it again it's
nothing about getting kicked in the nuts
it's called A Hard kick in the nuts what
I've learned from a lifetime of terrible
decisions there you go there you go yeah
so the questioner asks about your your
methane fart mask and the risk of it
blowing up were you near any possible
spark or flying at the time no but but
they're there's a pretty fascinating
newer one
um to to explain to you the the fart
mask was uh
it was kind of like it it was a sphere
like a globe
um kind of looked like an astronaut mask
type of thing and uh it was sort of
sealed around the neck and it had a hose
coming out of it and the hose I had had
a funnel and my buddy Preston held the
funnel up to his button and farted into
it now the reality is that I don't see
any possible way that any of that fart
actually made it through that whole hose
and into the mask but what made the bit
visually successful was that I just have
such a a hyperactive imagination the
idea that something might be gross
historically has just set me off barfing
so just as he he uh held this this hose
up to his butt I just start barfing in
The Mask like oh God I didn't smell
anything it didn't even need the smell I
didn't even need this help and there was
not a um uh the danger of a spark inside
the mask but for for our our most recent
Jackass movie which came out this year
called jackass forever they brought in
um a big water tank with uh this sort of
a seating situation in it and
um this great guy from Mythbusters Tori
balechi who had an underwater torch and
there was this mechanism to capture
farts completely underwater so it'd be a
bubble of of air but it's it's fart air
right right and and bring in uh bringing
up the torch to light it under water now
I could not believe the blast that that
caused and in hindsight it makes sense
to me because like the the philosophy of
a pipe bomb if you try if you take an
explosion and try to contain it what
you're actually doing is just magnifying
it yeah that's correct that's correct so
let me ask you this does it follow that
that that same magnification of the
explosion from a pipe bomb would apply
to an underwater fart they don't like
well so that the fart bubble is being is
completely surrounded by water which is
much denser than the air itself and so
any explosion any explosion is the re on
you know in the atmosphere is a is a
high temperature spot that wrap because
of the high temperature rapidly expands
the air around it and it's the expanding
air that we think of as the explosion
and if it's a weapon they put like BBS
and nuts and nails and things in it and
you get like a grenade that the
expanding air turns the the shrap note
into because there's there's the
shrapnel that's just the residue of the
bomb itself but there's the shrapnel you
can put in on purpose right and that
becomes individual projectiles that can
each become deadly in this case you have
rapidly expanding bubble but the bubble
has its size right if you try to make
that bubble any bigger instantly
what's the water gonna do the water is
not going to compress it has to fly out
of the way it can only just bust out of
the way so it would it would make a much
it was a brilliant setup because it
would make a much bigger explosion in
the water than it would if you just did
it in the air because then that's just
air expanding into air
I couldn't believe it it caught me
completely off yeah yes so if you did it
if you did it in a balloon if you wanted
to like be physics mythbustery about it
you do it underwater and it explodes the
water out of the way but if you do it in
a balloon and then explode that it'll be
like a pop but it's not going to be a
massive thing because it's just pushing
other squishable things around it called
the atmosphere I I remember I sound like
I had been kicked in the nuts oh my God
the blast of the underwater part like it
was the wire went flying everybody's
like whoa
it was a real uh like I think that that
was my my favorite moment of our most
recent Jackson I love it I love it and
just to round out the methane
conversation
um we we have found methane on Mars
oozing out from the sides of Ravines and
so there are many because Mars doesn't
have oxygen in its air so uh so where
people are wondering are there microbes
buried beneath the surface undergoing
anaerobic metabolism metabolism without
oxygen and then it would be releasing
methane so that's one uh appearance of
methane like in our backyard look for me
it's our backyard Mars uh and a moon of
Saturn called Titan the temperature is
so low that methane that's on that moon
has liquefied
so they're actually rivers of methane
going into lakes of methane on Saturn's
moon Titan so methane it is a really
um
uh it's a fascinating uh molecule that
is sort of the foundation of so much of
what's going on uh in in organic
chemistry so oh one other thing at
Cornell University they have a huge
agriculture school where they have cows
that are there for to study they study
the the lactation the you know the the
three however many four stomachs however
many they have and one of them they
carved open a side of the cow and you
can see into this and put a Plexi window
I I would think the cow would care about
this but apparently they don't and you
could just see the food come in and get
digested they collect the cow farts and
they burn the cow farts in the winter
to keep the barn warm
so it's one closed thermodynamic system
so yeah there's a lot going on with
methane
so do you sir have questions for me
I do we've got we've had a very short
amount of time there's two things that
uh that come to mind as my bigger
priorities
um I've heard this saying that we are
not human beings having a spiritual
experience but rather We Are Spiritual
Beings having a human experience and
I've read different things that talk
about how as spirits
we before we incarnate into this
physical body that we we choose our
parents that we we uh that there's a
blueprint for the for the experience the
the word seeking to have as in the human
body
um and that as part of the blueprint
there are uh life events which are
predetermined that are gonna like just
happen have you ever heard any of that
stuff before I've heard about it just
briefly but what I would say is I I
think it's it's a beautiful concept
right and turning the tables on
something that religious people feel
deeply that we are a corporeal
experience hosting a spiritual entity be
it your soul or anything else right and
you turn the tables on that and it's
you're talking about a spirit looking
for a body or creating you know going
through the body Factory just and
ordering two
ordering up a la carte what kind of life
experience you wanted your body to have
that would make an amazing science
fiction story if it hasn't already been
done and so I'm intrigued by the concept
but what I can say as a scientist is if
I'm going to apportion my confidence
that something is true I'm going to
apportion that confidence according to
how much evidence supports it okay so
you're saying not a lot of evidence to
support evidence to support Spirits
floating around choosing bodies and
their parents and life this is not a lot
of evidence for that I love the idea
though I mean that that wouldn't be you
know that's in the mix of fun sci-fi
ideas that people have made movies about
so I'm all in on it I'll be the first in
line at the at the IMAX but um
yeah I just don't see evidence for that
yeah right okay now um
it when we talk about
um like what happens after the the end
of our physical body
we don't that we don't have a lot of
evidence for that either huh
well so here's here's what we do have
um consider that many people who have
sort of near-death experiences and they
they come back some of them say oh I saw
a light and that wanted to follow the
light and no one follows up on that to
then report that they were near death
they were brought back to life in the
hospital on an operating table that has
a light over the table okay Ronnie so so
if you if you're dead and then you're
coming back you know in half
Consciousness and you see a light we got
it for you all right that's the blight
over the operating table and there are
people who say that they have an out of
Body Experience where they look down and
see their body so you can test for that
here's what you do all right you get
your relative to write something down on
a card okay and put it up above the
light facing upwards so if you have an
out-of-body experience and you look down
on yourself you should be able to read
what's on that card so that when you
come back to life you'll say oh it said
order me a slice of pizza or whatever
the you know has to be seen simple
saying and that has yet to be duplicated
as an experiment so for that's for the
out of body people and in terms of what
happens to you of course reincarnation
people are all about that right they're
totally in on you taking on another form
another human form or if you're uh you
know in India there's you come back
either as a different animal or a lesser
animal if you were not good so there's a
lot of people thinking about this all I
can say is that there's evidence from
people who have strokes mini strokes
and you systematically you can do the
the the grain scan and parts of the
brain start shutting off
bit by bit if rather than a catastrophic
stroke I'm talking about little bitty
strokes and they lose their language
they lose their ability to identify you
lose their ability to speak and this
just accumulates until they lose their
ability to do everything
and then they're basically brain dead
so this is evidence that everything you
are
is manifested in the electrochemical
impulses in your brain
and when those impulses go away we got
nothing left for you except the body
and why by the way your body has energy
content you know how the methane
molecule has energy so does the
molecules in your body it's just not
highly flammable it's not as energetic
as a but your body can burn all right
the fact that something Burns means it
had energy as part of it paper burns
because there's energy locked into the
the the the molecules that were once
wood in that paper and it gets released
in the form of heat so your dead body
um if you cremate it that your the your
body's energy becomes flames and that
energy radiates into space
where it moves at the speed of light
Across the Universe
so in a way you're still out there
the energy that was once in you so
that's a little bit of a spiritual
thought that actually has root truths in
physics and thermodynamics what about
Life review have you ever heard of that
where
is this why you're dying and you see a
whole life unfold in front of you yeah
yeah I'm intrigued by that
um I I know that that's happened to me
even when I knew I wasn't about to die
but there was some emotionally stressful
moment it was like whoa that was kind of
freaky so maybe it's not that you're
about to die therefore this happens
maybe you're there's a little your brain
is has been jostled in some way and it
releases these memories that are all
there but at different times of day
depending on whether you've had coffee
or Red Bull or whatever whatever is your
stimulant of the moment you can have
different depths of access to your
memories
and I try to make sure you ever see
people now uh what was it uh some the
pope was visiting a city somewhere and
the pope was going by in the Pokemon and
everybody had out their smartphone and
they're looking at the Pope in the
smartphone I say it's the pope put down
your smartphone and look at the pope and
create a memory on that what are you
doing and so or anything they pull out
the screen and they're looking at their
screen and I'm thinking people forgot
how to cherish a singular memory
they just want to record it on a
three-inch screen and watch it back on a
three-inch screen and then it's not a
memory anymore it's just it's a repeat
yeah it's crazy
um I I spoke my first words in
Portuguese
um I I spoke Spanish in Nursery School
um and uh and I my parents spoke English
I spoke three languages by the age of
three and forgot two of them completely
by the age of five
however when I was 11 years old at
summer camp these kids uh who spoke
Portuguese maybe they were from Brazil
maybe Portugal they said they were
freaking out they said that in my sleep
the night before I was speaking
Portuguese in my sleep now I had no
access to to this language however it's
in there okay were you uh a Portuguese
Conquistador in an early life were you I
know my father was the president of
Pepsi Cola in Brazil oh oh my gosh okay
so there's some Portuguese rootstock
there in some way so what I would say
there is uh we need better evidence than
just the eyewitness testimony of your
fellow campers and next time this
happens have them set up a recording
device right and then we can listen back
and have experts analyze it and not just
I heard you speaking Portuguese because
consider they have Portuguese filters in
their brains so if they hear words out
there they just hear syllables
utterances and you know to hear
Portuguese they could be selecting
Portuguese syllables right I'm pretty
sure you're not composing complex
sentences in your sleep so we're just
talking about utterances here it could
be that they cherry-picked the bits and
pieces and say I heard you speak
Portuguese so to head that off you want
to do get data on it and record it so
that we can then bring it to the lab
it's just future advice for you I think
that's fantastic man I'll tell you what
Neil I I wish we could talk for longer
and uh it's great I'm just I'm glad to
know you're alive and you have a high
sperm count before your vasectomy and
you now your smart account is presumably
zero yeah yeah I went in for the test
afterwards there was not even a corpse
on the battle Shield not a quartz on the
bed not even when the gut threw on
crutches right okay
it's been a delight to chat with you
thanks for being my uh host and and
guest all rolled up in one we knew you
had it in you and likewise man thank you
hey good luck on your tour and and the
sale I'm more closer to books than to to
to theaters I mean I've done work in
theaters before but for me as an
academic the book is the forever record
of what you've done yeah but if someone
doesn't show up at your show then unless
it's on Netflix or something they don't
see it they don't experience it but the
book is your chance to speak Through the
Ages and so I'm glad you have a book out
there as well that too this one's my
second second what was the first one
it's called professional idiot a memoir
all right I'm gonna go back to that one
first and read that one before we
continue all right dude thanks for being
on Star Talk hey thank you Neil all
right this has been start talk a special
Cosmic queries Edition with the one and
only Stevo who's apparently still alive
this has been Star Talk Neil deGrasse
Tyson here your personal astrophysicist
keep looking up
[Music]